now it doesn't just stop with the four
women plus all of the Miss Teen USA
pageant contestants who have accused
Trump of misconduct as the New York
Times and other publications reported
earlier Donald Trump's rape trial has
been scheduled for a hearing and
numerous accusers are now surfacing
federal judge Ronnie Abrams has ordered
a December status conference hearing
after a woman who calls herself Jane Doe
filed the lawsuit claiming that Donald
Trump raped her when she was 13 years
old in the 1990s now I've talked about
this two or three times now corporate
media does not want to pick this up and
even when some pundits talking heads on
corporate media mentioned you know by
the way there is a lawsuit against Trump
and Jeffrey Epstein for rape corporate
media seems to want to go away from that
this is the third attempt that the
plaintiff has made in filing this
particular lawsuit last Friday she filed
an amended complaint with a new witness
named John Doe who will apparently
corroborate the plaintiffs allegations
this dates back to 1994 95 and this new
John Doe says Jane Doe told me exactly
what it is that she is alleging in the
lawsuit sexual contact by mr. Epstein
and Donald Trump the complaint alleges
in no uncertain terms that Jeffrey
Epstein had a woman pick up teenage
girls from his uh from their homes for
his famous parties one of these girls
was the plaintiff in this lawsuit and
there's another witness named Tiffany
who provided an affidavit in the lawsuit
who says she personally saw Donald Trump
and Epstein rape the plaintiff several
times we're talking about a kid here of
course Donald Trump has repeatedly
denied the allegations now for all the
[ __ ] talk that Trump has tried to
redirect to Bill Clinton who's not
running for president Trump has some
real problems here
I don't know Pat whether this is Bill
Cosby 2.0 or whether we should call it
herman cain redux or just orange bill
cosby as i like to call it but these are
major major issues just three weeks out
from the camp
Payne now conveniently this hearing is
not until December so some some have
written to me saying you know this is
deliberate so that it won't affect the
election I think the entire Trump sexual
assault situation is absolutely
affecting the election right now the
polls show that well could you imagine
if things do swing and he does get
elected then you have the
president-elect going to court court
proceedings yeah over a rape case I mean
that's just not gonna play well in the
public eye imagine for a second November
8th Trump is elected president of the
United States November 9th he is now the
president-elect not scheduled to be
sworn in until January and December 16th
or whatever exact day this is he has to
show up to defend himself at a case
where he is accused of raping a minor I
mean it is just out of this world and as
I mentioned earlier countless women now
coming out of the woodwork also erin
burnett a CNN host erin burnett in
addition to all the other claims she
said Oh a personal friend of mine told
me that Donald Trump just forcibly
started kissing her on the lips and and
a completely unwanted sexual contact
that is what we call assault ladies and
gentlemen and it is absolutely
unbelievable that this is going on if we
were to write this the day Trump
announced his candidacy if we were to
say well he's going to win the
nomination and then after that he is
going to implode by doing everything
from ridiculing disabled journalists to
being accused of inappropriate sexual
contact in the contact known by too many
a sexual assault by a multiple women I
wouldn't have believed it I don't know
if many people in our audience would
have believed it I've talked about how
people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is Zipcar which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone
then you unlock it with your zip card
each car share member reduces their
personal co2 emissions by between 1100
and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join zip car
comm slash david support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zip car
comm slash David